[Music]
on this Wednesday night foreign funds
and claims of meddling the Toronto
businessman at the center of Chinese
interference allegations the Chinese
government aims to export its ideology a
global news exclusive
China's president confronts Canada's
prime minister
what that was all about and Trudeau's
response the investigation into the
missile that struck Poland why NATO says
it appears it was not a deliberate
attack
and to the Moon
the potential giant leap for lunar
exploration
with Donna Friesen good evening and
thanks for joining us Global News has
uncovered more detail about how a large
sum of money was allegedly transferred
from the Chinese Consulate to an
election interference Network including
Federal political candidates and their
staffers and we have more information
about the Toronto man alleged to be at
the center of that operation all of this
relates to the story Global News
investigative reporter Sam Cooper first
broke last week about foreign
interference in the 2019 federal
election tonight Jeff Semple delves
deeper into the new information that's
emerged
in 2019 China's president welcomed
visitors for an overseas Chinese
conference and among the honored guests
greeted personally by Xi Jinping was
torontonian Wei Changi
way is the owner of foodymart a
supermarket chain in Ontario NBC he's
also the permanent honorary chairman for
the confederation of Toronto Chinese
Canadian organizations or ctcco the
umbrella group has held numerous
pro-beijing rallies in recent years and
sources say way is now the subject of
two separate investigations involving
allegations of foreign interference back
in January sources say the Canadian
Security officials met with prime
minister Justin Trudeau and several
cabinet ministers sources say that the
officials presented a series of briefs
and memos outlining how the Chinese
government is allegedly targeting Canada
through a series of foreign interference
campaigns including an attempt to
influence the 2019 federal election
sources say way helped to facilitate the
transfer of around 250 thousand dollars
from the Chinese Consulate those funds
were allegedly sent first to an Ontario
MPP and a federal candidate staff member
from there sources allege the money was
distributed to a network of at least 11
Federal candidates along with campaign
staffers according to the briefs the
recipients included both liberals and
conservatives and some though not all
were aware of the source of the funds
the Chinese Communist party has been
taken advantage of this multiculturalism
of Canada in a free and open Society of
Canada to do its political agenda here
in 2014 Doris Leo was filming a
documentary on a planned Confucius
Institute for Toronto
The Proposal sparked protests from the
Chinese community over fears the Chinese
Cultural program is a propaganda tool
for Beijing so this is Mr Wei Changi way
and the ctcco were involved in a
counter-protest to support the Confucius
Institute Leo says participants were
bussed in and the pro-beijing rally
coincided with a lavish cultural event I
was filming there and I was wondering
where did money come from sources say
the Chinese Consulate provided one
million dollars to finance rallies
supporting the Confucius Institute and
sources say some of those funds were
funneled through whey and the ctcco
through these so-called cultural
exchange programs
the Chinese government aims to export
its ideology RCMP sources say
investigators are also probing ways
alleged links to several properties
including this one near Toronto
allegedly used by Beijing as so-called
police stations to conduct surveillance
and even forced repatriations against
members of the Chinese Community
Way did not respond to repeated attempts
to contact him including at his Toronto
office I'm from Global News we've been
trying to reach him Global News reached
One Man by phone who identified himself
as a ctcco official he called the
allegations nonsense the lawyer for the
Ontario MPP allegedly involved whom were
not naming told Global News there is no
truth whatsoever in the allegations of
your unnamed and clearly unreliable
alleged Source the way the Chinese
government operates to develop what we
call agent of influence bringing them
close to legitimate elected officials is
their primary target nope criminal
charges have been laid against whey and
there's nothing illegal per se about
local proxies transferring money that
says this security expert is the problem
Canada needs now urgently to equip
itself with a foreign interference law
to empower authorities to crack down on
foreign interference Jeff simple Global
News Toronto
Canada's prime minister and China's
president met face to face twice on the
sidelines of the G20 meeting in
Indonesia and that second meeting was
tense Xi Jinping berated Justin Trudeau
for revealing to the Press what they
discussed in their first meeting their
exchange was caught on the Canadian
media pool camera here it is
let's create the conditions first
the two leaders shook hands at the end
but it clearly shows the frustration of
the Chinese president Global's Mackenzie
gray is traveling with the Prime
Minister he breaks down that exchange
and what it could mean for china-canada
relations
Donna it's the second time in as many
days that Justin Trudeau and Xi Jinping
spoke but this time the cameras were
rolling Canadian media captured the
confrontation between the two leaders
she clearly annoyed that Justin
Trudeau's office shared details of their
last conversation
that's not the way the conversation was
conducted the Chinese president kept
going this time telling Trudeau if
otherwise it's hard to say what will
happen
before that Veil threat could be
translated Trudeau fired back
free and open and Frank dialogue while
Trudeau talked she looked away not
making eye contact a handshake and a
smile was she before walking away
shooter gives a quick word to his chief
of staff as Katie talford watches on I
won't
shy away from being open with Canadians
even as we discuss important and
sometimes delicate subjects at the heart
of she's complaint a senior government
Source telling reporters yesterday that
true to when she had a 10-minute
conversation about Ukraine North Korea
and Chinese interference Global News
first reported that China allegedly
spent nearly a quarter million dollars
to fund 11 different candidates in the
2019 election today Trudeau wouldn't say
if what he brought up was she was the
alleged election interference I raised
the issue of interference with our
citizens and expressed that it's
important that we continue to have
dialogue about that but it was the
dialogue that she expressed that had
some experts concerned
is essentially or else and so you know
that is a kind of phrase that say uh
Mafia Thug might might say to to someone
to intimidate them in the eyes of China
these conversations between Trudeau and
she never happened the Chinese Foreign
Affairs Ministry never put out a readout
and a spokesperson said they had nothing
to share at this point that's in stark
contrast to Canada's allies like the U.S
Australia and France who all got
official sit-downs with Xi Jinping Donna
all right Mackenzie gray in Bali
Indonesia thank you the Canadian Border
Services Agency says it's received death
threats against prime minister Justin
Trudeau during the so-called Freedom
Convoy protests in February the threats
including that the Prime Minister should
be hanged came to light during testimony
today at the emergencies act inquiry
during cross-examination of the former
head of the cbsa government lawyers
revealed the threats were received via
the cbsa website the missile that landed
in Poland dominated the final hours of
the G20 meeting an emergency meeting was
convened of leaders from G7 and NATO
countries there were a few tense hours
fears the war in Ukraine might be
spilling over into neighboring countries
today NATO's Secretary General Yen
soldenberg said it does not appear it
was a deliberate attack
based on what we so far know
this is most likely a Ukrainian air
defense systems or missiles but again
this is not Ukraine's fault what exactly
happened and who is responsible is still
being investigated and NATO countries
including Canada are supporting that
investigation Crystal commencing Reports
the fear of being next haunts those near
the explosion site in pashavadooth local
and international investigators are on a
fact-finding mission searching for
missile fragments on the Polish side of
the Ukrainian border
Poland's president gathered his
colleagues to discuss preliminary
findings saying unequivocally what
happened in the tiny farming Village was
not an intentional attack
Ukrainian air defense were firing
missiles in various directions and there
is a high chance that unfortunately one
of those missiles fell on polish
territory
after the strike Tuesday which killed
two people polish officials revealed the
missile appeared to be Russian made
Ukraine has Russian weapons in its
Arsenal but
Vladimir zolensky says based on his Air
Force Commander's information he does
not believe it was his country's missile
that impacted Poland he's asking for
access to the site saying Europe is his
partner
Russia acknowledged it Unleashed Mass
strikes using air and sea based
long-range systems that day but says it
did not Target anything near the Polish
border even if that's the case NATO
countries such as the UK say Russia is
still responsible the only reason why
missiles are flying through European
skies and exploding in European Villages
is because of Russia's barbaric invasion
of Ukraine Canada has offered
investigative support and is standing by
Ukraine this is an unjustifiable and
illegal War exacted by Vladimir Putin
with no end in sight to the war and
Russia's continued Reliance on aerial
assaults there's no way to guarantee it
won't spill over again
it could have been me says this farmer
the head of NATO offered reassurance
saying Eastern Europe is protected and
that the alliance will defend its
territory should it come to that
Crystal commencing Global News London
here at home the latest inflation
numbers are out and for the first time
since June Canada's Consumer Price Index
did not see a drop it held steady at 6.9
percent that's the same as September
although still high Canada's inflation
rate is doing better than the United
States which is at 8.2 and the United
Kingdom which at 11.1 percent today it's
also well below some of the hardest hit
countries like turkey where inflation
sits at an astonishing 83.5 percent lots
of Canadians are struggling though and
as Anne gaviola reports so are some
small businesses
economists were expecting worse but
inflation is still too hot prices at the
pumps climbed nearly 18 percent mortgage
interest costs more than 11 percent
higher than this time last year dry and
fresh pasta prices up nearly 45 percent
margarine 40 percent lettuce 30 percent
The Soaring price of lettuce is more
than Garden variety inflation a key
growing area in California was hit with
diseased crops in a growing season
plagued by drought and extreme heat many
restaurants are cutting way back on
portion sizes and some have replaced
Iceberg and Romaine on the menu trying
to make it stretch trying to make sure
like we use every last bit of it and
then so next week we're changing the
menu again as we normally do to try to
include as little as lettuce as possible
Metro and Loblaw both reported higher
third quarter sales today Loblaw's
growth driven by both Food and pharmacy
purchases but smaller retailers in
particular continue to struggle with
price pressures labor shortage changes
and lots of consumer demand they're
being hit uh from all sides at the
moment it's sort of a perfect storm for
a lot of businesses UTB and Calgary is a
small shop feeling the pinch in a way
that big box stores aren't it's leaning
on local suppliers to reduce supply
chain and shipping related costs we
aren't bringing in the really expensive
winter jackets because we know that
those families can't do it so we're
trying to Source a less expensive items
but keep our quality with inflation
still elevated money markets expect yet
another interest rate hike from the Bank
of Canada in December but this time a
moderate 25 basis point increase and
gaviola Global News Toronto
is it round two coming up why Ontario's
education workers have set another
strike date plus Quebec's Health
Minister says he's worried about a spicy
cocktail of viruses
more than 50 000 education workers in
Ontario are poised to walk off the job
again they filed another strike notice
this fight started with a focus on
services for students
we will not abandon parents just because
Doug Ford waves a loonie in our face
the Canadian Union of public employees
which represents education workers says
although both sides agreed to a one
dollar raise in hourly wages the
provincial government is refusing to
fund improved student services and
hasn't met demands for higher Staffing
levels Ontario education Minister
Stephen leche calls the potential new
strike unfair and unnecessary if a deal
is not reached the union says it will
launch a full strike on Monday
Health officials in both British
Columbia and Quebec are recommending
people wear masks in indoor public
places as the triple hit of respiratory
viruses is straining the Health Care
System neither province has plans to
reintroduce mask mandates
and I do not believe we need that heavy
hand of a mandate to send a clear
message that mass are an important tool
that we can all use during this time and
in every respiratory season
Quebec's Health minister is recommending
Mass be worn in all crowded public
spaces saying what he calls the spicy
cocktail of flu RSV and covid is gaining
Steam and increasing the burden on an
already overloaded Health Care system
president Trump's past ahead the
circumstances overshadowing Donald
Trump's bid for a return to the White
House
in the U.S media Outlets are projecting
that Republicans have gained control of
the House of Representatives from
Democrats flipping seats in key
Battleground districts in the midterm
elections Democrats still control the
Senate so President Biden now faces
dealing with a divided Congress to get
legislation through also Donald Trump
has made it official the man who claims
the 2020 election was stolen and who
inspired a deadly riot in an attempt to
keep himself in power wants to run for
president again the question is does the
Republican Party want him Jackson prosco
reports please repeat
singing the song of angry men defeated
twice impeached and perhaps soon to be
indicted Donald Trump is back
campaigning as a self-anointed savior in
order to make America great and glorious
again I am tonight announcing my
candidacy for president of the United
States his last campaign ended in lies
and a violent attempt to cling to power
this time the former president is
desperate and aggrieved and I'm a victim
I will tell you I'm a victim Trump's
great comeback launched from the same
Resort where the FBI recovered hundreds
of Highly classified documents just days
after Republicans suffered their worst
electoral results in decades at the
hands of Trump's Mega candidates I
didn't need this I had a very nice easy
life it's a this is something I didn't
need increasingly Republicans feel the
same way Fox News cut away from the
speech now we're going to go back to
former president Trump when news
warrants while the once trump-friendly
New York Post buried the news under the
headline Florida man makes announcement
this is just two minutes drama and too
much problems it certainly is the most
wounded Donald Trump has been he rode
into his first campaign on a wave of
hype and reality TV stardom
Trump 2.0 is built around a damaged
former president fending off potential
Republican Challengers and multiple
criminal probes though prosecutors are
unlikely to be deterred this will not be
my campaign this will be our campaign
altogether
though Trump is not to be underestimated
he now has to weather an unprecedented
in two years of campaigning the road
back to the White House has never looked
longer Jackson prosco Global News
Washington
to the moon and back next NASA's latest
Mission and what it means for Humanity
and space exploration
and liftoff of Artemis one we rise
together back to the moon and Beyond
that liftoff was certainly a spectacle
NASA's Artemis one rocket is finally on
its way to the moon and 25-day test
flight which finally got off the ground
after months of delays caused by
technical problems and back-to-back
hurricanes there are no humans on this
flight but if it goes as planned there
soon could be Eric Sorensen explains the
mission and the role Canada is playing
the most powerful rocket ever built is
on its way
will take a week for Artemis 1 to get to
the Moon it will Zoom Around The Far
Side flying just a hundred kilometers
above the surface it will Circle and
then slingshot into a distant lunar
orbit before it returns to earth 25 days
from now after weeks of delays from
hurricanes and hydrogen leaks NASA is
finally putting Artemis without a crew
through an arduous test drive to ensure
it'll be safe for astronauts we are
stressing it and testing it in ways that
we will not do to a rocket that has a
human crew on it 60 years ago the first
astronauts scarcely knew what to expect
from space travel every step was a
breakthrough the risks were enormous and
there were tragedies the technology
primitive by today's standards computing
power inferior to what's in your iPhone
and yet Tower cleared in July 1969
humans would fly to the moon and walk on
it here man from the planet Earth
foreign America now we are going back to
live and work on the moon and eventually
on Mars and this time Canada will be a
crucial part of it the Next Generation
canadarm the high-tech jack of all
trades tool will help build and maintain
an orbiting space station
a lot more advanced capabilities to
science to move filos and stole payloads
around the lunar Gateway station
eventually a lunar base will be
established we're really hoping that it
will lead us foundations for a
sustainable human and robotic
exploration of of the moon in the future
because of this country's contributions
one of four Canadian astronauts will be
chosen to fly on the next mission
Artemis 2 in 2024 Canada will be only
the second country in the world to have
an astronaut fly around the moon this is
quite important and it speaks about our
leadership in space Artemis one is
scheduled to splash down in the Pacific
December 11th starting a new era for a
new generation Bound for the moon Eric
Sorensen Global News
Ottawa
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
year Canada is near Burley Falls Ontario
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
thank you
[Music]